we're learning that a close call for an
American Airlines flight at New York's
JFK Airport was apparently far worse
than first reported sources tells CBS
News the Airbus plane with 102
passengers and eight crew on board
nearly crashed last week when the wing
scraped the ground and hit a sign and
light pole during takeoff here's the air
traffic control audio Kris Van Cleave is
at Reagan National Airport near
Washington with new details on this Kris
good morning this is scary to hear this
how bad do they think it could have
crashed good morning it is very scary
and remarkable calm from the pilots
they're given just how dangerous of a
situation they had just gone through on
American Airlines flight 301 source told
me they came as close as anybody would
ever want to come to crashing and those
are words not to be used lightly given
the ongoing investigation here sources
familiar with that probe say the initial
indications are there was a loss of
control right at takeoff take a look at
this picture from a passenger on board
flight 300 that shows some of the damage
to the wing here the Airbus a321 took
off around 8:40 p.m. last Wednesday
April 10th it was bound for Los Angeles
just as the plane was beginning to lift
off its nose wheel coming off the ground
the plane banked rolled sharply to the
left that caused the wingtip to scrape
the ground the wing then hit a runway
sign and a light pole before the pilots
managed to regain control and continue
the takeoff
the force of the impacts bent the wing
the flight managed to return to JFK 28
minutes later with no injuries reported
American Airlines says it is
investigating this incident in
coordination with federal authorities we
know the National Transportation Safety
Board has requested data from this
incident that the board has yet to
launch its own investigation the FAA is
investigating they have
not determined why the plane banked so
sharply right at that critical moment of
takeoff John thank you Chris I'm gonna
look forward to getting the final answer
on that